bonjour à tous merci de me retrouver sur
public sénat à suivre sur notre antenne
l'audition de gérard rameix le médiateur
du crédit qui a été choisi pour succéder
à jean pierre jouyet à la tête de
l'autorité des marchés financiers pour
cela il fallait que gérard rameix bien
obtienne le feu vert du parlement
il a donc été entendue le 25 juillet par
les sénateurs
et c'est son audition que je vous
propose de suivre tout de suite mes
chers collègues
si vous le voulez bien nous allons
entamer avec un peu de retard dont nous
vous prions de rapporteur général et moi
même de bien vouloir nous excuser ainsi
que notre hôte gérard rameix s'en vont
pouvoir entamer cette audition nous
connaissons bien le cadre juridique
puisque nous avons auditionné dans ce
même cadre juridique il y a quelques
jours jean pierre jouyet qui depuis lors
a été confirmé en qualité de directeur
général de la caisse des dépôts et des
consignations
donc dans ce cadre juridique c'est à
présent gérard rameix et qui est devant
nous et qui est devant nous parce que
jean pierre jouyet et directeur à la
caisse des dépôts et consignations ce
n'est que la suite logique des choses
car jean pierre jouyet était président
de la mef et il s'agit de pourvoir à
cette présidence et le président de la
république a proposé la candidature de
gérard rameix l'assemblée nationale vous
a auditionné et ceci dans le cadre du
cinquième alinéa de l'article 13 de la
constitution président de la république
ne peut procéder à une nomination que
lorsque l'addition des votes négatifs
dans chaque commission
représente au moins trois cinquièmes des
suffrages exprimés au sein des deux
commissions lors c'est beaucoup moins
compliqué que le trading à haute
fréquence ou que les opérations sur les
marchés de dérivés donc gérard rameix
mais manipule et toutes ces techniques
extrêmement complexe avec dextérité
depuis longtemps mais il est lui-même
soumis à ce à ceux à cette conjonction
de chiffres qui devra s'opérer au sein
de nos deux commissions des finances
il va falloir consolider nos votes avec
ceux des membres de la commission des
finances de l'assemblée nationale
je vous rappelle que d'après l'article 3
de la loi organique prise en application
de cette disposition constitutionnelle
il ne peut y avoir deux délégations lors
d'un scrutin destiné à recueillir l'avis
de la commission permanente compétente
de chaque assemblée sur une proposition
de nomination selon la procédure du
cinquième alinéa de l'article 13 de la
constitution conséquence seuls les
présents ventron et nous voterons en
remontant dans notre salle habituelle
des séances puisque cette audition et et
public et toute audition de cette nature
et public conformément à la loi
organique précitée
par contre le vote lui sera plus discret
comme il se doit et aura lieu dans notre
salle des séances et la présente
auditions et retransmise en direct sur
le site internet du sénat alors monsieur
gérard rameix
en accord avec le rapporteur général je
vous proposerais bien volontiers de bien
vouloir de façon synthétique en dix
minutes
c'est la règle du grand oral dans les
bonnes maisons ça continue comme ça il
n'y a pas de lumière qui va s'allumer à
la fin de la dixième minute mais mais
mais c'est quand même bien dans le même
esprit je dis ça puisque vous en êtes
passé par là nous sommes quelques-uns en
est passée par là donc en dix minutes
pouvez vous nous livrez votre vision de
l'autorité des marchés financiers de ses
responsabilités de son avenir en europe
et ensuite nouveaux questionnements et
vous connaissez bien la mf puisque vous
allez nous le rappeler vous avez été
sauf erreur de ma part secrétaire
général de la cob il ya déjà quelques
années puis la mf qui a été créée par
qui a été créée en quelle année là mfg
rapporter tout ça mais j'ai une capacité
d'oubli qu'est la vie considérable 2002
donc vous avez été directeur général de
l'aeem des services de la main aux
fesses getis directeur général de la cob
et secrétaire en dessous jours vous avez
été directeur général de la cob et
secrétaire général de l'aeem f
ceci donc pendant un certain temps vous
avez vécu notamment la création du
collège des sanctions et vous avez donc
une très grande expérience d'aidé de la
législation boursière de la mise en
oeuvre de la législation boursière
vous avez par définition très souvent
rapporté devant le collège de la mf et
et vous allez pouvoir sans doute nous
résumer cette expérience et qui vous
vaut certainement la proposition
formulée par monsieur le président de la
république donc monsieur gérard rameix
vous avez la parole
ensuite le rapporteur général et moi
même peut-être vous demanderont quelques
opinions sur des sujets de fond et
l'ensemble des membres qui voudront vous
questionnez pourront le faire
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur général mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs
je suis très heureux d'être devant vous
en tant que
candidat pressenti pour la présidence de
l'autorité des marchés financiers alors
je commencerai peut-être par dire
pourquoi j'ai lorsque l'idée m'a été
présenté j'ai répondu immédiatement
présent ça transparaît un petit peu
d'ailleurs dans votre exposé monsieur le
président d'abord parce que je
m'intéresse depuis très très longtemps à
la régulation financière
j'ai joué un rôle personnel non
négligeable dans la conception de
l'organisation actuelle de la mf
notamment sur la dualité commission des
sanctions collège j'ai constitué moi
même beaucoup d équipes qui sont encore
à la mf et donc j'ai toujours suivi ces
sujets la deuxième raison c'est que peu
de temps après avoir après douze ans
dans la régulation financière quitter ce
domaine j'ai repris du service dans un
domaine connexe puisque je suis
actuellement médiateur national du
crédit aux entreprises est en même temps
président de l'observatoire du
financement des entreprises et en un mot
la grande conclusion que je tire de ces
travaux c'est que du fait de bâle iii
sur lequel nous reviendrons peut-être la
tendance dans les prochaines années ça
ne se sent pas encore beaucoup mais dans
les prochaines années va être à une
réduction relative du financement
bancaire et à une montée des
financements alternatifs
parmi ces financements alternatifs il
est crucial pour l'avenir de l'économie
française que les financements de marché
se développe
or l'ambiance sur ce terrain là me
paraît exécrable pour tout dire vraiment
les la mission majeure de la mfc de
protéger les intérêts des épargnants et
sans que ce soit je pense la faute de la
mf mais la conjoncture sur les marchés
entre l'explosion de la bulle
l'éclatement de la crise des subprimes
les l'effondrement des cours par exemple
l'été dernier sur des attaques sur les
titres bancaires
on peut dire que l'épargnant à être
français est d'ailleurs européens en
général a été extrêmement chahutée et il
n'a pas dû sans doute à voir et je le
regrette en tant qu'ancien régulateurs
et peut-être futur
le sentiment d'avoir été assez protégé
donc il m'a semblé que ayant quand même
capitalisé une expérience importante à
partir du moment où ça m'était proposé
je ne pouvais que qu'accepter ce nouveau
challenge de présider le collège j'ai
toujours cru à l'importance de la
collégialité pour une raison extrêmement
simple c'est qu'à partir du moment où le
parlement confie à une autorité
administrative indépendante au lieu de
le confier au gouvernement une série de
responsabilité et bien la responsabilité
politique et transférés au collège qui
rassemble des c'est son intérêt c'est je
pense ce qui motive la décision du
parlement de constituer une grille qui
rassemble des points de vue différents
pour essayer de définir et d'appliquer
les meilleures règles possible donc le
fait d'avoir un collège est quelque
chose de majeur
et quand j'étais secrétaire général j'ai
toujours conçu ma fonction comme étant
véritablement au service du collège et
j'essayais en quelque sorte à chaque
fois de donner le pour et le contre
sur toutes les décisions pour que le
collège puisse puisse décider
donc je n'ai pas de problèmes
psychologiques majeurs à passer de la
position de secrétaire général à celle
de président même s'il faudra que je me
limite peut-être dans certaine volonté
d'être trop proche de l'exécutif puisque
j'aurai la responsabilité du collège
général secrétaire général ils
travaillent plus que le président oui ça
me permettra de travailler peut-être un
peu moins j'ai beaucoup travaillé en
tant que secrétaire général en c'est de
notoriété publique en très très grande
harmonie presque complicité avec le
président de l'époque qui était le
prédécesseur de jean pierre jouyet qui
était michel prada qui a accompli une
oeuvre internationale en particulier
extrêmement importante et je pense que
je devrais approfondir mon expérience
sur ce terrain notamment je regrette
beaucoup que les positions françaises au
sein de l'esma est assez curieusement
plutôt recul et je crois que jean pierre
jouyet le regrette aussi nous payons
peut-être nous en france le fait d'avoir
eu le bénéfice de la localisation
géographique puisque vous savez que
l'esma est à paris mais au début
le secrétaire-général de césar était
français le président du collège de la
coop il a aimé jouer un rôle très
important c'est plus le cas aujourd'hui
et ça me parait fâcheux et donc
j'attacherai personnellement une grande
importance à l'esma alors sinon vous
m'avez demandé de dire quel est l avenir
de la mf pour moi mon premier réflexe et
c'est dans un environnement extrêmement
mouvant avec des évolutions très rapides
de ne pas oublier les fondamentaux il ya
il ya quatre piliers à l'action de la mf
et je vais les décliner très très vite
pour rester dans les limites
la première chose c'est d'être capable
de d'enquêté et de punir lors s'il ya
des dérapages par rapport à
l'application des textes
je suis abasourdi par exemple par ce que
j'ai appris dans la presse sur le libor
alors c'est pas immédiatement
directement dans le champ de la mf mais
elle peut quand même contribué sans
doute aux investigations ce qui s'est
passé est proprement scandaleux et
lorsqu'il ya des choses comme ça il faut
être très présent
la deuxième chose c'est l'information
financière
vous savez qu'en théorie financière
le prix de marché le juste prix en
permanence à content parce qu'il intègre
la totalité des informations qui sont
délivrés on peut avoir quelques doutes
sur la perfection de cette théorie mais
en tout cas ce qu'on sait c'est que si
l'information est caché et bien le prix
ne peut pas être bon et donc c'est un
combat de tous les instants de la part
du régulateur d'obtenir des émetteurs de
titres qui sont cotées sur les marchés
réglementés ou sur des plates formes
voisines d'ailleurs de et qui sollicite
les parkings publics de donner les
informations qui sont nécessaires et je
suis bien placé pour savoir que c'est
pas toujours facile d'autant que les
informations sont de plus en plus
complexes à vrai dire à donner la
troisième chose qu'on oublie parfois un
petit peu c'est la gestion d'actifs la
mf et le grand régulateur de tous les
professionnels qui commercialise ou qui
gère des produits financiers qui sont
proposés au public
c'est une activité très importante
quantitativement la gestion française
est une des plus grosses gestion du
monde et nos grandes entreprises de
gestion ont des filiales dans le monde
entier
elle propose des produits qui peuvent
parfois être complexe il est très
important que la déontologie
et puis la technique de description des
produits tout ça soit à la hauteur
c'est le troisième domaine le quatrième
domaine englobe un petit peu tous les
autres c'est véritablement
l'international je pense qu'on ne le
dira jamais assez le temps où la cob
faisait la pluie et le beau temps sur un
marché français qui étaient largement
autonome et est complètement terminée
maintenant dès que vous investiguer sur
une situation de marché
vous vous apercevez que de nombreux
ordres parfois la majorité sont venus
d'autres places financières que celles
de paris
il convient de savoir quelles sont les
règles que ces plats s'applique si on
veut me prononcer les sanctions ou alors
on est dans des interprétations sur la
territorialité des choses donc je
reviens à l'instant
le fait d'avoir une régulation
européenne la plus unis possible et est
une
une nécessité absolue on en est encore
assez loin et deuxièmement les
conceptions européenne doivent être
portés à ce qu'on appelle la hausse qu
en anglais l'oicv en français qui est
l'international des régulateurs de
marchés avec la sicile à effet s'abriter
nique etc
et je pense que c'est une des tâches de
la mf traditionnellement elle elle l'a
toujours fait beaucoup avec une optique
à ces consuméristes assez protectrices
de l'épargnant mais qui doit quand même
tenir compte encore une fois de
l'extraordinaire évolution des
techniques donc pour terminer cet exposé
je pense que je suis techniquement assez
près que j'ai pris un peu de recul sans
m'éloigner du monde de la finance que je
connais les limites et les difficultés
du rôle du régulateur pour les avoir
éprouvés dans de nombreuses situations
et que je suis donc plutôt bien placé je
pense un sans forfanterie pour assumer
ce rôle si les parlementaires veulent
bien approuvé les intentions du
gouvernement et du président de la
république
merci monsieur le président merci
beaucoup monsieur rameix alors monsieur
le rapporteur général le témoin est à
vous merci monsieur le président et je
remercie monsieur rameix des indications
qui nous a déjà apporté en introduction
je voulais compléter l'information de
nos collègues au travers des questions
auxquelles il faudra bien répondre la
première porte sur son parcours vous
nous l'avez un peu explicite et nous
avons nous le sentiment que la fonction
de secrétaire général que vous avez
occupé avec efficacité et la fonction de
président du collège sont des fonctions
sensiblement différente
peut-on considérer que l'expérience
acquise est un atout est-ce que les
qualités requises sont les mêmes vous
nous avez parlé des capacités de travail
qui sont pas apparemment tout à fait les
mêmes au niveau des fonctions mais je
pense que c'est surtout au niveau de la
différenciation entre les rôles exercée
par ce que il ya une séparation
fonctionnelle entre le secrétaire
général qui décident de l'ouverture des
enquêtes mais le collège qui est
l'autorité de poursuite et le fait que
vous ayez quitter la mf voilà seulement
trois ans serait-il par exemple de
nature à remettre en cause certaines
procédures en cours c'est une question
qu'on peut se poser
ensuite peut-être pourriez-vous nous
donner votre sentiment sur les moyens
actuels de la mfs que vous pensez être
en mesure de répondre à à tous les taux
des exigences que vous mentionniez tout
à l'heure dans votre développement avec
des moyens existants qu'est ce que vous
pensez des noyades à votre disposition
quel est votre sentiment sur la place de
paris qui votre prédécesseur nous
l'avait explicité il ya quelques
semaines quand ils nous avaient rendu
compte de des activités de la mf la
place de paris qui a essayé par exemple
sur les obligations d'avoir une
stratégie offensive
une stratégie de développement avec
aujourd'hui
francfort et londres qui ont tout de
même des stratégies relativement
avancez et puissante est ce qu'on peut
envisager d'aller plus loin pour
renforcer notre place
et bien sûr cette centralisation à
londres vaut surtout pour toutes les
compensations dérivés alors est-ce que
sur ce terrain vous avez quelques
explications utiles à nous fournir puis
sur la ttf bien sûr c'est aussi un sujet
qui peut interroger pensez vous que cet
été puissent être réalisés au niveau
européen sans le royaume uni cette aune
aux mains des paramètres importants
lorsque on s'intéresse à la régulation
financière à l'échelle européenne et la
place de l'on a tendance toujours à
vouloir s'extraire du dispositif commun
sur la ttf on aimerait avoir votre
sentiment
alors j'en viens quelques questions sur
l'encadrement des marchés parce que
c'est bien là le sujet majeur en
définitive on a mis en place la
directive marchés d'instruments
financiers votée en 2004 mise en place
en 2007 et
elle a contribué à une fragmentation des
marchés d'actions sans que les vertus
supposées de la concurrence soient
vraiment au rendez vous dont kiel en ce
moment au regard de ce constat un projet
de révision de la mif avec donc mif 2 en
cours de discussion au niveau européen
donc notre question c'est comment vous
pouvez pesé dans cette discussion quels
sont les points qui vous paraissent
devoir être changée puisque la
régulation est jugé insatisfaisant telle
qu'elle se produit actuellement
qu'est ce que vous pensez en particulier
des projets controversés de création
d'une nouvelle plateforme au tf
et puis on a bien sûr des interrogations
sur le marché des quotas de co2 est
également sur le marché des matières
premières
sans oublier le trading à haute
fréquence bref on sent bien qu'il y à
au-delà des orientations dans lesquelles
s'est inscrite la directive mif
aujourd'hui une effervescence qui est
constaté à l'échelle européenne dans
toutes les initiatives pour aller plus
loin parce que la régulation empêche la
sphère financière de tourner comme elle
avait pu le faire dans le passé et le
trading à haute fréquence par exemple
nous démontre à quel point aujourd'hui
on essaie de contourner et de passer au
travers des mailles de ce système de
régulation
donc comment cette discussion mif 2 peut
conduire à des évolutions favorables et
comment pensez-vous pouvoir peser dans
cette discussion à l'échelle européenne
enfin je crois qu'il ya une question qui
nous tient à coeur
on s'est interrogé en recevant un
certain nombre d'interlocuteurs ces
derniers temps sur le financement long
de l'activité économique dans notre pays
c'est un souci que nous avons tous vont
bien qu'il ya une tendance de l'épargné
aller vers le très court terme vers le
liquide et par rapport à ça évidemment
nous pouvons nous interroger sur les
instruments autre que fiscaux parce que
la fiscalité peut être un atout mais
mais y at il d'autres instruments
position complète ma question
une façon un peu orienté je trouve mais
man et y at il à vos yeux d'autres
instruments qui permettrait de cette
réorientation de l'épargné c'est une
bonne question dans le moment de toute
façon cette fois non et puis enfin
dernière chose
l'éventualité de création d'une bourse
spécialement dédié aux pme et aux pays
est-elle une idée qui vous tient à coeur
vous avez écrit un rapport remarqué avec
thierry j a mis sur le financement des
pme donc je pense que c'est un sujet que
vous connaissez bien et c'est aussi une
préoccupation aujourd'hui que nous avons
dans cette nouvelle mandature réorienter
les moyens d'intervention vers les pme
par les différents outils à notre
disposition la création de nouveaux
outils donc la bourse pme pourquoi pas
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous dire à ce
sujet voilà monsieur président quelques
questions pour éclairer un peu mieux la
candidature de monsieur rameix s'il veut
bien nous répond bien si beaucoup le
rapporteur général donc mesuré mexes
comme vous le voyez vous êtes inciter à
faire un panorama à nous permettent de
préciser le panorama sur toute une série
de questions cruciales et permettez-moi
un ajout ponctuelles dans le sens
d'ailleurs des questions du rapporteur
général et le marché des quotas de co2
la commission des finances du sénat
c'était force et d'approfondir cette
problématique et notamment vous l'avez
cité tout à l'heure avec l'aide de
michel prada qui a délivré un rapport
important sur ce sujet et pour nous il
s'agit bien d'un marché d'instruments
financiers
est ce que ce qui doit permettre
d'assurer la sécurité nécessaire des
transactions la transparence des
transactions et nous savons que des
aléas sont survenus que dès que dès que
des fautes ont été commises dans
certains pays et sur ses marchés qui
sont interconnectés sur le plan européen
et il serait utile que vous puissiez
nous faire part de votre réflexion à cet
égard et sur le rôle que paris peut
jouer parce que c'est naturellement
derrière toutes nos questions techniques
le souci que nous avons est ce que paris
va être autre chose dans les années à
venir car les institutionnels d'une
autorité intégrer
est-ce que les colonnes que vous avez
évoquées sont des colonnes solide ou
simplement des colonnes des colonnes en
carton des colonnes en faux marbre sans
chapiteau bien bien et bien une bien
solide bien bien caractéristique ccc en
particulier je terminerai par là le
doute la préoccupation que nous pouvons
avoir sur les marchés de matières
premières
l'avenir de la régulation à la française
sur les transactions de contrats
matières premières
en d'autres termes l'avenir du matif
est-ce qu'il ne sera pas sacrifiée et la
régulation française avec lui dans le
cadre de l'évolution de niles euronext
évolution qui fera très certainement à
la place de londres qui conférera la
place de londres un rôle encore plus
important dans les années à venir et la
france grands pays agricoles dont la
première banque même si elle a des
difficultés le credit agricole
quelle est l'ambition qu'elle peut avoir
pour être une place de référence en
matière de négoce sur les contrats de
matières premières vous avez le choix
entre douze septèmes et voilà vous allez
les voir et de les traiter nous aider à
être un peu plus intelligent sur tous
ces sujets ça montre la diversité de la
matière si vous voulez bien je vais
avant de prendre les questions par une
je vais en prendre deux qui me
paraissent vraiment fondamental c'est
l'avant dernière question de monsieur le
rapporteur général sur le financement de
l'activité puisque la finance a pour but
de financer de façon rationnelle les
économies c'est sa mission première il
faut pas qu'elle oublie et deuxièmement
la place ce qu'on peut faire à paris
alors sur le financement si vous voulez
moi j'ai deux convictions
la première j'ai déjà exprimées jeu
l'arrêt exprime toutes choses égales par
ailleurs le modèle financier français
qui repose avant tout pour les
entreprises moyennes et intermédiaires
sur un financement bancaire est un
modèle qui est n'ont pas mis en cause
mais menacés au moins marginalement par
les accords de bâle iii
donc il faut que nous préparions à avoir
des solutions de financement alternatif
alors je peux pas faire un exposé là
dessus très très long parce que il ya
heureusement beaucoup de solutions
possibles ce qui est certain c'est qu'il
serait de l'intérêt général que beaucoup
de ces solutions passent par le marché
alors je pense à des solutions de
inspirée de la technique de la
titrisation même si le mot a été un peu
discréditer même largement discrédité
par la sphère des subprimes je pense
aussi à des affaires de cession de
portefeuille
vous avez eu par exemple d accord récent
entre deux grandes banques et un grand
assureur le plus grand assureur français
qui a accepté de reprendre 80 % d'un
portefeuille de crédit de bancaires
accordés par chacune de ces maisons qui
sont le crédit agricole et la société
générale
vous pouvez vous avez aussi des des
propositions d'opcvm qui regrouperait
des investisseurs pour investir dans des
obligations
d'entreprises intermédiaires ou moyenne
alors que traditionnellement le marché
obligataire est sûre dès qu'on appelle
des grands corporate il ya toute une
série de solutions comme ça moi je pour
pour dire de façon synthétique
je pense un qu'il faut les explorer
systématiquement et deuxièmement qu'il
faut au maximum passer par des
mécanismes de marché qui ont le mérite
de donner la liquidité et un prix le
plus juste possible
la deuxième conviction que j'ai elle est
un peu dans votre question monsieur le
rapporteur général c'est que il y à une
un problème de nécessité de
transformation
c'est à dire que l'ambition le choix
naturel des épargnants français qui sont
de gros épargnants c'est d'épargné à ses
cours et de prendre peu de risque et
malheureusement ce qui s'est passé
depuis dix ou quinze ans elle les a
plutôt renforcé dans cette conviction
or tous les économistes et tous les
hommes et femmes d'entreprise savent que
on a et on aura besoin de fonds qui sont
plus longs et qui sont plus risqué donc
quelques en même temps les régulateurs
regarde la transformation avec suspicion
puisque traditionnellement c'était des
banques qui prenaient des ressources
courte et qui investissait plus long
maintenant on leur dit que c'est
dangereux et on leur impose des ratios
très important donc il faut absolument
travailler non seulement à des solutions
des produits intermédiaires que les
assureurs par exemple peuvent souscrire
comme le dans l'exemple que je donnais
et il faut aussi regarder par tous
moyens comment on peut convaincre dans
des conditions transparentes un an et
est aussi protectrice que possible le
public de consacrer une partie de ses
actifs qui sont encore une fois très
important à des emplois plus long alors
la fiscalité est un des moyens elle
n'est pas le seul il ya toute une
réflexion j'avais participé à la demande
du premier président de la cour des
comptes et du président de la première
chambre des travaux que la cour a fait
sur l'assurance vie sains et elle vient
de publier un rapport sur le financement
qui est assez important je pense que ce
sera un des sujets et 10 ont modestement
mais sans trop de modestie quand même à
la mf je pense qu'en tant que régulateur
la mf peut apporter sa pierre à celle de
mise en adéquation des ressources et des
emplois dans le domaine de l'épargnant
alors je suis un peu moins optimiste
pour être franc sur sur la place de
paris
non pas que nous n'ayons pas d'atouts
qu'est ce que nous avons comme atout
nous avons des grandes banques
nous avons des grands gestionnaires
d'actifs et nous avons des grandes
entreprises cotées qui ont leur siège à
paris ça c'est trois atouts très
importants
en revanche on n'a pas la tradition de
la finance de marché et deuxièmement on
peut dire que les choix collectifs qui
ont été faits en particulier par les
grands acteurs financiers que sont nos
banquiers n'ont pas été en faveur du
développement du marché à paris c'est à
dire que sans entrer dans le détail
jusqu'à une époque récente et bien les
les institutions de plats salés des
organismes de règlement livraison de
compensation ou l'entreprise de marché
était en partie contrôlé par des acteurs
français et c'est de moins en moins le
cas
c'est plus le cas avec l'entreprise de
marché puisque elle est contrôlée en
fait part des fonds qu'ils qu'ils sont
internationaux en réalité et vous savez
tout ce qui se passe sur le règlement
livraison et sur la compensation
on a beaucoup de mal à faire que
l'essentiel le coeur des opérations
reste à paris et notre ambition pour
l'instant c'est que ce qui est vraiment
sur des produits français reste à paris
mais on est assez mal placé dans la dans
la compétition internationale
alors je ne prétends pas que la mf
honnêtement puisse contrer ce courant
elle peut s est un acteur très avertis
qui a la première responsabilité c'est
de conjointement avec la cp l'autorité
de contrôle prudentiel de vérifier que
que les institutions quels que soient
ceux qui les contrôlent apporte la
sécurité nécessaire elle peut au delà
essayer de mobiliser un peu la place
pour que au sein du concert européen on
soit dans des grands acteurs mais il
faut bien reconnaître que ces dernières
années on n'a pas marqué de points et on
a plutôt été déçu par ce qui s'est passé
en dépit du fait que nous sommes des
grands utilisateurs de la place alors je
pense que l'aspect sur les sur les
questions de gouvernance en particulier
d'entreprise
le fait que nous ayons une grosse
tradition de gestion devrait nous
inciter à des modèles dans dans la
mobilisation de l'actionnariat je le dis
en passant sur questions connexes sur la
bourse des pme
je vais vous pas vous infliger le résumé
du rapport que j'ai fait avec mon ami
thierry giami j'ai trouvé que
l'inquiétude des chefs d'entreprise les
chefs inquiète
l'inquiétude des chefs d'entreprise
étaient légitimes cette virée chefs
d'entreprises français s'était adressée
à christine lagarde puis à françois
baroin en leur disant la place s'éloigne
de nous l'entreprise de marché préoccupé
des grandes opérations de fusions
internationales ou des opérations de
dérivés qui sont très rentables et le le
fait d'attirer en bourse des entreprises
moyennes ou intermédiaire passent au
second plan et ça nous semble ça nous
semble inquiétant nous nous avons repris
cette thèse je pense qu'elle est
juste et nous avons proposé que on
réorganise les marchés je pas trop
entrer dans la technique mais
principalement en disant qu'au sein de
niles euronext il devait y avoir une
équipe dédiée qui s'occupe avant tout
des entreprises intermédiaires et des
entreprises moyennes je crois que c'est
une bonne piste et j'ai eu la grande
satisfaction de voir que tout récemment
à l'occasion des entretiens annuels de
paris europlace euronext soit même à a
finalement retenu cette thèse
notre rapport avaient été qualifiées de
dures il était effectivement assez
sévère parce que après un bon dialogue
au début de notre mission est bien
ensuite les dirigeants de nice euronext
avait semblé tout à fait inactif dans le
dialogue avec nous ne voulait pas se
prononcer alors je pense qu'on tombait
un très mauvais moment parce qu'il était
en train de négocier avec
malheureusement l'insuccès la fusion
avec la bourse allemande et donc nous on
avait entendu marc est véritablement la
direction qu'il fallait prendre sans
prendre trop de précautions
diplomatiques et je crois que finalement
ça a été une bonne technique et j'espère
qu'on va avancer là dessus ça serait une
des unes d un des moyens de renforcer
aussi la place de paris nous avons fait
des déplacements avec thierry giami deux
fois en allemagne et une fois à londres
pour voir que ce sujet était pris très
au sérieux dans ces pays là et nous
aurions grand tort de le négliger
alors je vais essayer d'être un peu plus
concis sur les nombreuses autres
questions malgré leur grand intérêt
bon sur la différenciation des rôles
entre le secrétaire général et le
président je ne suis pas très inquiet
puisque j'ai observé pendant des années
quel était le rôle du président je pense
qu'à part une responsabilité générale il
ya une responsabilité de communication
de gardiens de l'image de l'autorité
c'est très important d'avoir une image
véritablement solide de sérieux de
professionnalisme de volonté de protéger
les épargnants tout en maintenant des
acteurs
au fait des techniques modernes on ne
peut pas tout les proscrire sur notre
place en faisant un petit îlot comme
chez astérix il faut faut rester moderne
tout en protégeant notre marché je pense
qu'il faut animer le collège s'assurer
que les services marche bien et je pense
que bon j'ai pris du champ par rapport à
mes fonctions de secrétaire général et
je pense que je peux faire c'est tenue
maintenant ça sera la pratique si vous
me faites confiance de le montrer sur la
question en quête poursuite sanction est
très pertinente
j'ai réfléchi un petit peu là la
séparation enquête poursuite est moins
importante pour les juristes que là que
la séparation entre poursuite et
sanctions néanmoins si jamais il
s'avérait que une enquête
arrive enfin sur mon bureau un rapport
d' enquête pour une enquête que j'ai
ouverte moi même je demanderai à un de
mes collègues du collège de présider le
collège pour ne pas avoir à prendre le
plus petit risque juridique en ce
domaine
vous avez remarqué peut-être à une
grosse sanction qui a été prononcé il ya
quelques jours c'était effectivement sur
une enquête que j'avais ouverte mais
c'était au stade de la sanction à mon
sens puisque je suis parti depuis trois
ans et demi les dernières enquêtes que
j'ai ouverte sont des enquêtes ouvertes
début 2009 en principe elles sont toutes
achevées mais sinon je prendrai cette
précaution sur le plan des moyens bon
jeu
je ne peux faire à ce stade une réponse
générale je pense qu'ils sont assez
satisfaisants
si vous voulez les équipes
préférerai toujours avoir plus de moyens
je pense qu'il faut surtout insister sur
les recrutements de grande qualité
parce que c'est un métier très très
technique et si on veut pouvoir sinon
tenir la dragée haute du moins être pris
vraiment au sérieux par des
professionnels il faut pouvoir recruter
les commissaires aux comptes les
financiers les juristes de bon niveau
mais je ne pense pas qu'il faille
multiplier quand même les effectifs
peut-être le secrétaire général et
moi-même demanderont certains moyens
mais je pense dans une de façon assez
limitées il faut voir que tout de même
lorsque je suis arrivé il ya un peu plus
de dix ans maintenant dans la régulation
la cob avait un peu plus de 200
personnes et le cmf une trente 30 35 et
aujourd'hui il ya maintenant quatre cent
cinquante personnes à la mf donc on a
quand même une taille qui sans être
énorme par rapport aux britanniques et
aux américains permet quand même de
jouer jeu et sur le plan juridique ont
faut toujours actualisé les moyens jean
pierre jouyet fait un gros effort en ce
domaine et le parlement l'a suivi ce qui
a été heureux sur un grand nombre de
points donc je ne vois pas d'énormes
trous dans la raquette à première vue
mais sous bénéfice d'inventaire puisque
j'étais quand même un peu plus éloignés
sur le terrain des obligations je suis
effectivement un peu déçu enfin c'est
une évolution qui vient de loin le
marché obligataire s'est éloigné des
particuliers et s'est éloigné des
marchés réglementés et les transactions
se fait sur des marchés de gré à gré
sans violer le secret professionnel je
peux vous dire que la cob en particulier
la haye mais dans ses débuts a mis à
jour sans que ça ait fait l'objet de
grandes publicités de véritable scandale
de véritable escroquerie commis par des
opérateurs sur le marché obligataire en
l'absence de prix de connaissance fine
des prix par les opérateurs eux mêmes
même des spécialistes et nous avons nous
nous sommes aperçus que 1 par exemple un
bloc de d'obligations données pouvaient
passer d'un assureur à l'autre en une
journée avec des gens qui au milieu
s'interposait et mettait de côté 500
mille euros ou quelque chose comme ça
pour des
des paquets d'obligations qui ensuite
allez rester dans les portefeuilles de
l'assureur
alors sur la durée si vous laisse y
rester trois ou quatre ans ça ne se
mesurait pas facilement mais si vous
inquiétiez vous aviez des opérateurs qui
en s'étant entendus eux-mêmes donc en
faisant des manipulations pas du court
puisqu'il ya pas de cours mais du prix
et en agissant avec des complicités
arrivé à truquer le marché donc je pense
que à la fois pour redonner de la de la
transparence un accès plus grand des
épargnants et l'action entamée qui
consiste à avoir un marché un marché
officiel si vous voulez réglementée sur
l'obligataire est quelque chose qui va
dans le bon sens alors je regrette parce
que ce qu'on me dit c'est que la
première étape a été franchie mais que
pour des raisons qu'il faudrait leur
demander les grandes banques les grands
courtiers ont encore convenance a
échangé sur le marché de gré à gré alors
même que tous les outils sont présents
sur le marché obligataire je prétends
pas résoudre à moi seul le problème mais
c'est quand même une question qui était
tout à fait importante
en plus de ce que j'ai déjà dit sur les
pme t il je suis persuadé qu'il va
falloir créer un marché c'est pas facile
d'obligations ou de pâques ou de groupes
d'obligations pour des entreprises
moyennes et intermédiaires qui n'auront
plus accès aussi facilement
qu'aujourd'hui à des financements
bancaires sur les dérivés c'est un
immense sujet le sujet essentiel si vous
voulez c'est de les faire passer par une
chambre de compensation alors c'est en
cours alors j'ai pas suivi tous les
détails dont je je préfère m'en tenir
aux grandes lignes il faut absolument
appuyer à fond ce ce phénomène de
centralisation l'explosion
invraisemblable des dérivés est quelque
chose qui peut très difficilement se
contrôler et de paris en tout cas ce
qu'on peut faire c'est faire que ce soit
pas une multiplicité de transactions
bilatérales mais que ce soit des
transactions organisées de façon à ce
qu'il y ait au moins une chambre de
compensation qui est les positions des
uns et des autres et qu'il est qu'on
pense ça permettrait d'éviter sinon tous
les périls du
du moins une partie alors sur la taxe
sur les transactions financières bonjour
je ne vous dirai pas des choses très
original 1 je pense que c'est
parfaitement possible et même tout à
fait souhaitable de il faut le faire
dans des conditions qui ne nuisent pas
trop à la place de paris est pas trop
aux places européennes
ac c'est aussi simple que ça on navigue
entre ces deux choses c'est faisable et
souhaitable parce que d'abord s'il y
avait une taxe peut-être y aura un peu
moins de transactions inutiles ou
d'ordre retirer ou de choses comme ça et
la finance dans son rôle économique
serait tout à fait aussi efficace et un
peu moins éparpillés dans ses moyens et
dangereuse dans ses techniques
donc c'est parfaitement possible en même
temps comme c'est une la matière la plus
fluide qui existent la matière
financière
si vous avez des places sur lesquels il
n'y a pas cette taxe il ya un gros
risque que les opérations les plus
contestables se déplace donc c'est là où
il faut des accords internationaux
importants
et voilà ce qu'on peut dire sur ce sujet
mais nous notre direction à suivre l
éclair dans une certaine mesure je pense
que si on a déjà un accord au sein de
l'europe même au sein de l'europe
continentale on peut déjà commencer à
faire quelque chose sur la mif
j'ai jamais été honnêtement un grand
laudateurs de l'amif la mif a été fait
par des gens qui était obsédé par l'idée
de faire baisser les prix
ça a marché dans une certaine mesure
mais je pense que ce qu'on a obtenu en
baisse de prix on l'a plus que reperdu
sincèrement sur le manque de clarté dans
la fixation des prix et sur la
fragmentation des marchés
alors je ne suis pas au fait de de tout
le détail des négociations 2002 mais
j'ai aucun doute sur
la nature des positions qu'il faut
défendre il faut essayer de faire en
sorte que le plus possible les marchés
réglementés qui sont eux mêmes en
concurrence les uns avec les autres
soit ne soient pas désavantagées
peut-être on peut pas les privilégiés
mais au moins ne pas les désavantager et
exigé que les principales plateformes
si vous voulez applique des règles
minimales garantissant qu'il ya un
processus de prix et de connaissance des
transactions suffisant quant à créer de
nouvelles plateformes qui seraient
encore différente de celle qui existe
j'ai pas encore étudié le sujet de façon
précise mais a priori j'en vois pas
franchement la nécessité on a déjà
énormément de plateformes
je ne vois pas pourquoi on en voudrait
d'autres mais honnêtement il faudrait
que je suis plutôt un technicien au
départ j'aime bien avoir le texte et
j'avoue je ne les ai pas encore étudié
sur le trading haute fréquence
bon c'est un mal moderne un nenê de la
technique
nous avions obtenu il ya quelques années
une sanction dans une petite équipe qui
était un peu d d innovateur dans le
domaine du trading de haute fréquence et
nous avons pu les sanctionner en
considérant que la rapidité avec
laquelle ils zen il envoyait les ordres
et les annulait constituer une
manipulation du cours
alors peut-être peut-on faire ça dans
certains cas sur des algorithmes de de
marché peut-être faut-il
tarifs et les ordres qui doit qui sont
retirés pour essayer d'éviter d'avoir
cette rafale de d'ordre qui en fait
attend plutôt accroître la volatilité
des marchés
alors je ne pense pas que ça nuise au
temps j'ai eu un débat hier avec
monsieur emmanuelli sur ce point oui il
avait l'air de penser que c'était
directement contraire aux intérêts de
l'épargnant qui veut investir en bourse
moi je lui ai dit que ce que je
conseillais un épargnant qui voulaient
investir en bourse en action c'était de
garder son titre longtemps c'est de
faire une analyse fondamentale du titre
et ensuite de garder ce titre en
portefeuille
si l'on fait cela le trading à haute
fréquence est un peu gênant et
désagréable mais nenê pas n'est pas
majeur en revanche plus vous plus vous
agissez à court terme
plus vous êtes défavorisés par rapport à
des gens qui ont des techniques et des
et des machines qui sont très supérieurs
aux vôtres et donc moi je pense que tout
ce qui doit être fait pour décourager
ces techniques sous réserve de ne pas
nuire à la place doit être faire là
encore il faut que je me mette à niveau
parce que le trading à haute fréquence
était un mot par exemple qu'on
n'employait pas lorsque j'étais
secrétaire général de l'aeem f pas du
tout parce que je le récuse et mais
c'était pas encore employé
donc ça montre que c'est en trois ans a
appris une une expansion extraordinaire
donc je vais réétudier cette question si
si j'ai la confiance de vous même et de
vos collègues sur sur les marchés de co2
et les marchés de matières premières
moi j'irai assez dans le sens que j'ai
cru deviner de votre part monsieur le
président c'est à dire et monsieur le
rapporteur général aussi d'ailleurs
nous avons une expérience des marchés
assez importante
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas eu
historiquement des positions très fortes
sur les marchés de matières premières
qui sont plutôt une invention américaine
ou ensuite une conquête londonienne mais
on a quand même de solides connaissances
de ce qui est un marché et on a intérêt
à considérer ces produits comme des
marchés financiers et à leur appliquer
les règles qui sont qui sont adaptés
pour des marchés financiers et donc je
crois qu'il faut aller dans ce sens-là
si on veut éviter les situations d'abus
de corner risation de conquête du marché
où le risque d'interruption d'un marché
parce que des opérateurs ne peuvent ou
ne peuvent plus dénouer leurs opérations
alors est-ce qu'on a la capacité comme
vous semblez le souhaitez de de
reconquérir des positions sur des
marchés de grandeur et de matières
premières
on parle beaucoup en ce moment des des
aléas du marché des céréales qui est qui
est un marché international
c'est vrai qu'on peut regretter qu'on
soit pas plus fort dans ce domaine je
suis pas sûr qu'on ait une capacité de
conquête extraordinaire en tout cas on
peut y travailler
ce que j'ai répondu à toutes les
questions je crois je crachais tenu à
peu près que le médiateur a épuisé la
matière mais enfin je ne donner qu'un à
quelques éléments alors j'ai des
demandes de parole de vincent delahaye
et jean germain
je vois également roger karoutchi qui se
manifestent yat-il jean paul emorine y
at il d'autres demandes de parole pas
d'autre pour le moment
alors la parole est au sénateur de
l'essonne maire de massy vincent
delahaye oui merci monsieur le président
mes chers collègues
monsieur le médiateur moi je partage vos
inquiétudes et effectivement sur sur le
marché en général et sur la confiance
des épargnants je pense y en a beaucoup
qui ont quitté le marché et je pense que
pour les faire revenir y avoir beaucoup
beaucoup de travail
alors ceci étant dit mais question très
plutôt à la gestion interne de la fff et
au rapport d'activité que on avait pu
regarder il ya quelques temps en
commission des finances et vous répondre
en partie à la première question que
j'avais sur les effectifs et sur
l'évolution des frais de personnel de la
mrc j'ai constaté qu'en 2011 a augmenté
de 9% que la rémunération moyenne qu en
tout cas le coût moyen d'un
salarié de la fff était de 70 mille
euros pour 450 personnes est-ce que
vous comptez quand même faire évoluer
cette masse salariale et ses effectifs
en fonction de l'activité
est-ce que vous avez des critères parce
que s'il ya moins d'opérations sur le
marché ce qui me semble être le cas
actuellement et qui pourrait durer un
petit peu moi je pense est ce que vous
comptez rajusté un petit peu ses
effectifs à la baisse
ça c'est ma première question deuxième
question c'est sur les fonds propres de
la ms j'ai vu qu'il y avait 55 millions
d'euros de fonds propres et je me posais
la question de savoir à quoi il servait
ses fonds propres
est-ce que c'est pas des taxes qu'on a
prélevé un peu indûment et qu'on a mis
de côté et comme la messe n'est pas un
opérateur de marché
et puis avec 55 millions je pense que on
serait vite bloqué en termes de montant
je me pose des questions sur cette
capitalisation qui pour moi n'a pas
beaucoup d'intérêt
et puis la dernière question ça a lieu à
la transporte à la transparence dans
l'apport d'activités on avait la
surveillance de la transparence des
sociétés par rapport à la communication
des rémunérations de leurs dirigeants et
j'aimerais savoir si vous vous engagez à
faire ce qu'il n'était pas dans ce
rapport d'activité c'est-à-dire donner
des informations sur la rémunération des
dirigeants de l'aef parce que je les ai
pas trouvés et sur leurs avantages voilà
diverses et variées non j'ai bien
cherché dans le rapport mais c'est vrai
qu'on la lui assez rapidement et voilà
moi j'aimerais j'aimerais avoir des
engagements de votre part sur cette
transparence nécessaire pour tout le
monde puisqu'on la demande pour les
sénateurs et pour les parlementaires en
général et je souhaite que cela soit le
cas pour tout le monde donc voilà je
profite de votre passage pour vous poser
cette question qui n'est pas méchante du
tour
merci à monsieur grenet la parole est à
jean germain sénateur maire de tours oui
merci monsieur le président ma question
à trépas directement au fonctionnement
de l'autorité des marchés financiers
mais à la philosophie générale facile
parce que on a une préoccupation quand
même de financement à la fois des
activités privées et des collectivités
territoriales
donc dans votre exposé on a bien
ressenti la présentation des choses mais
je voudrais en être sûr donc et un
financement traditionnel
les banques les assurances avec des
autorités de contrôle
et puis s'est développé depuis quelques
années et plus en plus rapidement
ce qu'on appelle la finance de marché
c'est à dire des lieux où finalement des
capitaux rencontrent ceux qui ont besoin
de capitaux pour se développer
généralement des entreprises mais aussi
maintenant parfois sous la contrainte
des collectivités territoriales et donc
il ya des actifs qui s'échangent qui
peuvent être des actions des obligations
voilà peut être un marché à court terme
à terme etc et dont vous nous avez parlé
de bâle iii en indiquant tous ceux qui
viennent devant nous le font d'ailleurs
de plus en plus en indiquant que la
réglementation qui s'impose sur les
banques est également sur les assurances
va rendre leur activité de plus en plus
difficile parce que ils auront besoin
pour gérer ce qui est important dans
l'économie capitaliste donc le risque
ils auront besoin pour gérer ce risque
finalement d'avoir des réserves un
certain nombre de règles prudentielles
ou pas qui font que finalement ces
organisations prêtent de moins en moins
finalement de capitaux de moins en moins
de capitaux et donc on demande aux
entreprises d'aller de plus en plus sur
les marchés financiers et on nous a
expliqué de nombreux soit qu' on n'avait
pas l'habitude en europe en europe et
notamment en france et peut-être aussi
en allemagne mais que c'était très
développé dans le reste du monde anglo
saxon d'un autre côté on nous annonce
que il va falloir que le modèle de la
banque universelle est terminé et qu'on
va subdiviser finalement les activités
des banques en 2 mai
j'arrivais pas bien peut-être suis-je le
seul mais il faut de la fois avoué
finalement sur son i know you son
ignorance
j'arrive pas bien à comprendre à
comprendre ce système qui visent de plus
en plus dont 40 difficile pour des
raisons diverses 1 mais une incurie des
risques inconsidérés un certain moment
les prêts par les banques ou dans le
même temps la bce essaye de l'or des
liquidités à court terme pour qu'ils
arrivent à faire des choses mais ils
peuvent plus le transforme et finalement
en crédit moyen ou long terme
on rentre de plus en plus difficiles
aussi les placements des assurances pour
diminuer les risques
on nous incite à aller sur le marché
financier donc on lui demande de se
réguler est de plus en plus et au fur et
à mesure que la régulation de plus en
plus importante sur un certain nombre de
secteurs
l'argent c'est change de plus en plus
ailleurs et donc au fur et à mesure qu
on nous demanderait une intégration en
europe de plus en plus importante le
marché des finances finalement
s'éloignerait de plus en plus de nous
alors je vis ça m'inquiète un peu
je voulais savoir si vous partagiez une
partie de cette inquiétude ou si c'était
du un provincialisme exacerbée qui nous
fait du bien chers collègues car les
questions que vous posez sont tout à
fait fondamentale et j'oserais dire que
je souscris très largement ce que vous
avez dit ô paradoxe que vous avez
exprimé c'est bien un point fondamental
que vous avez abordé alors à présent le
ministre roger karoutchi
le président oui moi je sais très bref
je voudrais bien me sur un mec ce jeu
c'est pas le sujet de par définition
s'il en est là si je puis dire et s'il
est là devant nous c'est qu'au niveau
des à la fois des compétences du
parcours
il ya une espèce d'unanimité bon et
c'est assez normal
en revanche moi je suis très sensible au
fait que depuis plusieurs années et eu
beaucoup de critiques sur la mf pas
pardon hein pas sur le fonctionnement
interne les moyens bon très bien ça
c'est normal
le futur président la mf devra s'en
occuper mais pour un citoyen pour un
épargnant et vous l'avez dit vous-même
l'inquiétude est là l'absence de
certitude ou en tout cas de garantie est
permanent et pèse lourdement sur
beaucoup de familles sur beaucoup
d'épargnants vous dites vous même les
épargnants se détournent les épargnants
n'ont plus confiance
mais finalement c'était le rôle de la mf
de rassurer de garantir d'informer de
protéger et aujourd'hui on se dit on va
peut-être que la mf et surdoué sur des
domaines techniques extrêmement
performant mais sur la protection des
épargnants sur l'information des
épargnants c'est pas terrible alors en
la matière vous l'avez reconnue vous
même
qu'est ce que j'allais dire vous
pourriez avoir comme proposition je vous
demande pas de définir une politique
complète de protection de l'épargnant
mais qu'est ce qui vous est apparu comme
manque peut-être dans les années
récentes sur cette protection est cette
information des épargnants pour les
faire revenir à 6 non à meilleure
fortune en tout cas à un meilleur
sentiment
deuxième élément est là c'est pas une
question c'est une observation sur la
place financière de paris en 2010 en
liaison d'ailleurs avec jean pierre
jouyet
nous avions fait un rapport
pour essayer de voir comment on pouvait
renforcer la place financière de paris
entre espèces de 2 de cohésion entre
ville de paris région ile de france
association des banques etc etc
ce rapport est sûrement très bien la
preuve c'est que nous l'avons cosigné
donc il était par définition remarquable
il est resté naturellement lettre morte
c'est à dire que toutes nos propositions
de la fin 2010 je pense en juillet 2012
n'ont pas connu le début d'un iota de
réalisation est ce que quelque part pas
seulement la mf d'ailleurs est ce que
quelque part l'ensemble des autorités
financières bancaires des grandes
entreprises installées à paris n'ont pas
acté le fait que maaf c'est comme ça il
valait mieux passer par londres il
valait mieux faire autre chose
mais est-ce qu'il ya encore une vraie
volonté aujourd'hui de défendre la place
financière de paris
la parole est au président jean-paul
emorine
merci de ce président michel qu'avec
moins de questions très rapide je
voulais poser à monsieur remake
vous avez évoqué ce rameix la taxe sur
les transactions financières comment
voyez vous le rôle de la mmf dans la
mise en oeuvre de cette taxe sur les
transactions financières la parole c'est
le dernier orateur inscrits pour le
moment non ce l'avant-dernier président
jean arthuis merci monsieur le président
de deux questions au moment où le
contrôle prudentiel va se roder anisé et
comment voyez-vous monsieur rameix le
devenir de la baisse au plan européen
d'abord à l'échelon de la zone euro
pensez vous que nous soyons à la veille
d'une
forme de rapprochement entre les
autorités de marchés financiers et ceci
pour tendre vers sans doute une plus
grande efficacité
deuxième question le rapport d'activités
la mer est tout à fait intéressant on
est étonné de ne pas y trouver un
rapport de certification de la sincérité
des comptes de la mf alors voulez-vous
dire qui contrôle les comptes de m f
et qu'est-ce qui s'oppose à ce qu'il
soit fait mention d'une opinion
attestant de la sincérité de ses comptes
savoir qui contrôle les contrôleurs ne
pas qu'ils se posent toujours président
charles guené oui merci monsieur le
président non je voulais simplement et
brièvement compléter peut-être
l'interrogation de notre collègue
germain pour demander à monsieur rameix
s'il ne pensait pas que bon là la perte
d' influence donc de la place de paris
dans le nouveau contexte bâle iii et de
deux transformations
notre système de régulation ne tenait
pas aussi d'une façon importante au fait
que nos amis anglo-saxons ont des fonds
de pension beaucoup plus important que
nous qui fonctionnent avec des systèmes
de retraite par répartition alors là je
crois last but not least joël bourdin
président de la délégation sénatoriale à
la prospective
hormis d'autres choses merci monsieur le
président une simple petite question
la msa dans ses missions le respect de
la déontologie en matière financière et
peut faire des observations peut même
aller plus loin que ça puisque elle peut
alerter les pouvoirs judiciaires
j'aimerais savoir s'il ya des réflexions
dans le cas de la mmf sur le mode de
fonctionnement et la composition
d'ailleurs des comités de rémunération
des sociétés cotées fois joël bourdin
alors monsieur rameix je vais vous
demander de bien vouloir rassembler vos
réponses à ces différentes questions
vous voyez que commission des finances
du sénat s'efforcent d'entrer dans le
détail des sujets qu'elle va sur le fond
des choses c'est peut-être un peu
différent du nôtre rassembler devant
laquelle vous êtes avait tout récemment
enfin bon nous aimons bien affirmé
notre notre différence et voilà donc à
vous de faire un joli paquet qu toutes
les réponses
voilà merci monsieur le président
finalement beaucoup de questions sur
l'ajustement des effectifs quand je suis
arrivé à la médiation du crédit rené
ricol avait rassemblé une équipe au
niveau national de 40 personnes elle est
aujourd'hui de moins de 20 donc c'est
pour vous dire que à titre personnel etc
c'est pas du tout parce qu'il y avait
trop de monde c'est parce que le nombre
des dossiers de médiation a baissé donc
j'ai baissé les effectifs en même temps
tout en ayant à coeur d'avoir des gens
de grande qualité
alors je dis pas que ce soit ce qu'il
faut faire à la mf parce que même si le
marché est pas extrêmement actif en ce
moment il le nombre des sujets abordés
justifie le recrutement de pas mal de
spécialistes mais enfin personnellement
moi je ne pense pas qu'une institution
est d'autant plus puissante qu'elle a un
grand nombre de gens sur les fonds
propres
il faut voir que la rfa est financé par
des toute une série de prélèvements qui
sont variables en fonction de l'état du
marché et donc il est assez logique
qu'elle est un fonds de roulement en
fait ces fonds propres représente ce
fonds de roulement alors bon 55 millions
c'est relativement confortable c'est pas
excessif
historiquement ça vient d'eux du boom
c'est à dire chaque fois qu'il ya eu un
boom de marché il ya eu un surcroît de
recettes et dans les périodes de vaches
maigres la mf reprend sur son fonds de
roulement
bon il faut la juste et je dirais qu'il
ya peut-être une petite marge de
manoeuvre mais c'est pas énorme
c'est faux sont placés d'ailleurs dans
le circuit du trésor sur la rémunération
des dirigeants et je ferai un paquet
avec le dernière question qui m'a été
posée par monsieur bourdin donc au
départ ce n'était pas une attribution
central de la mf que la gouvernance
d'entreprise
elle s'en est occupé pourtant dès le
dès le temps de la cob en essayant de
pousser le patronat les associations
patronales l'afep et le medef à
apprendre des textes ensuite à la suite
de l'éclatement de la bulle il ya eu un
travail législatif qui a été assez
important donc la mfc a calé son action
dans ce cadre là alors il est permis de
penser que la transparence n'a pas eu
tous les résultats escomptés puisque
ceux qui étaient en faveur de la
transparence pensais que ça entraîne à
une certaine modération
il a fallu attendre plusieurs années
pour que le niveau des rémunérations
soient publiquement critiqué pour
parfois le caractère vraiment très
important de ces rémunérations
je pense que le fait de donner peut-être
davantage de responsabilités à
l'assemblée générale des actionnaires de
l'informer voir de lui donner un pouvoir
de fait on peut
oui moi je serais plutôt je serais
plutôt favorable même si j'ai pas aurait
étudié ce sujet c'était pas dans ma
fonction à la médiation du crédit
mais je pense si vous voulez que enfin
dans une économie aussi agitée que celle
qu'on connaît les à coups de
rémunération et en général dans le sens
de la hausse des dirigeants sont pas
compris
donc il faut il faut que les
actionnaires aient à coeur de d'avoir
une stratégie cohérente que une
stratégie victorieuse rapporte beaucoup
d'argent aux dirigeants c'est normal
lorsqu'il ya des difficultés c'est pas
forcément le moment d'augmenter sa
rémunération de 15 ou 20%
on sait des choses de bon sens mais
apparemment le bon sens et pas
contrairement à ce que disait descartes
partagés en ce domaine là sur la
transparence à l'intérieur de la nef
je crois que la rémunération du
président est fixé par mesure publiée au
journal officiel
j'avoue que je pourrais pas vous dire de
tête laquelle ce qui implique ma naïveté
d'ailleurs elle est quand même elle
permet de vivre sans égaler celle des
plus grands acteurs de la place
en tout cas vous la trouvez au giro on
la mettra dans le rapport annuel y'a pas
de problème là dessus
moi je suis pour une politique plutôt
généreuse de rémunération pas pour le
président il faut laisser des autorités
en débattre mais pour l'ensemble des
cadres pour deux raisons d'abord il faut
des gens compétents et deuxièmement il
faut être à l'abri des tentations
si vous voulez faire faire un travail de
très grande qualité par des gens qui
sont en face de gens qui sont très bien
payés
il vaut mieux que vous n'êtes pas les
payer autant parce qu'on n'y arrive pas
mais à avoir quelque chose correcte
sinon vous avez des gens qui sont
frustrés au total pas compétent ou alors
qu'ils viennent chez vous uniquement
pour apprendre la technique qui partent
juste après donc je pense que c'est pas
une très bonne économie donc le chiffre
de rémunération moyenne là je ne l'avais
pas en tête mais il m'a pas il me choque
pas en tant que tel sur le mode de
fonctionnement des comités de
rémunération je pense qu'ils pourraient
être améliorés on a vu on a vu dans
quelques affaires que les comités de
rémunération qu on vraiment il était mis
sur la sellette finissait par faire le
travail mais quand ça reste entre amis
parfois ce sont les mêmes membres qui
sont filiales et participations croisées
et donc ça facilite l'échelle de
perroquet donc je pense qu'on aurait on
pourrait améliorer les règles pour
l'instant à ma connaissance si vous
voulez il n'y a pas de règle
fondamentale à part la présence
d'administrateurs indépendants et jeu
je pense qu'on pourrait progresser là
dessus pour être pour être francs sur
les fonds de pension bon c'est un très
vaste sujet en france on a quand même 12
100 milliards qui sont dans l'assurance
vie
alors c'est quelque chose qui est un peu
un substitut aux fonds de pension en
france alors malheureusement ce ne sont
pas des fonds de pension donc d'abord
ils sont assujettis à des règles
différentes
les règles de la directive solvency 2 ce
baby t2 ne sont pas applicables aux
fonds de pension alors qu'ils sont
applicables aux compagnies d'assurance
lorsqu'elles gèrent des actifs
d'assurance vie y compris les contrats
en euros
donc ça défavorise toutes choses égales
par ailleurs l'investissement en actions
et c'est un financement qui est moins
long que celui des fonds de pension donc
c'est vrai que dans un monde idéal on
pourrait souhaiter avoir des fonds de
pension mais alors transformée pour
partie nos assurances vie en fond de
tension c'est pas évident en revanche je
tiens à vous signaler que et je pense
que tous les gouvernements successifs
quelle que soit leur couleur ils y ont
contribué
on a donné naissance à une épargne
salariale qui sans être à la hauteur des
dés et être à la hauteur des fonds de
pension américains ou anglais commencent
à remplir a rassemblé plusieurs dizaines
de milliards d'euros qui eux sont
beaucoup investis en actions
donc ça c'est une bonne chose je pense
c'est un problème à traiter dans le
cadre de ce que je disais tout à l'heure
sur les financements plus longue puisque
des fonds de pension sont des fonds qui
sont exposés s'il voulait a une durée
longue ça ne veut pas dire que la
technique des fonds de pension soit
idéal c'est quand vous avez des fonds de
pension qui gardent des taux
d'actualisation très très élevés alors
que les rendements sur le marché baisse
eh bien ils peuvent eux mêmes dans leur
gestion rencontré des difficultés très
importantes alors sinon la question les
questions de monsieur germain sont très
pertinentes en réalité je m'adresse à
modestie alors les collectivités
territoriales d'abord il faut qu'elles
se comportent comme des gestionnaires
normalement prudent et j'avoue que avoir
réussi à vendre à des responsables
financiers de collectivités locales à
l'occasion de près des swaps sur le yen
sur le dollar
c'était quand même singulièrement
étrange et c'était abusif alors je pense
qu'il ya faute des deux c'est à dire que
sincèrement je pense qu'à faute de celui
qui a pris le contrat parce qu'il
suffisait de lire et de voir qu'on peut
on échange et un taux d'intérêt faible à
court terme mais avec un risque énorme
sur le swap et ça il n'y avait pas
besoin d'être agrégé de finance pour le
comprendre
et deuxièmement pour les équipes
bancaire qui se sont amusés à cette
commercialisation
c'est vraiment très très critiquable
même si j'ai pas fait d'en quête là pour
le coup puisque c'est arrivé un peu
après mon départ sur alors maintenant il
faut éponger pour les pots cassés vous
êtes certainement plus donc moi sur le
sujet parce que c'est un c'est un sujet
qui est quand même très difficile pour
certaines collectivités territoriales
alors sur la régulation si vous voulez
dans le domaine bancaire
alors je prête emprunt pas me substituer
à à christian noyer 1
c'est vrai que plus on régule une partie
du domaine plus les opérateurs audacieux
ou peu scrupuleux essaye de déplacer
leurs opérations vers les zones d'ombré
alors j'ai pas la martingale total 1
je pense que le fait de d'isoler la
partie banque de détail et la partie
banque de marché ne répond pas à toutes
les questions mais va plutôt dans le bon
sens ça va rassurer vous et moi qui
avons notre compte de base dans une
banque on se dira qu'on est à l'abri
d'opérations fantaisistes en banque de
marché ont néanmoins on voit bien que
l'expérience de la crise montrent que
des banques de détail ont fait des
bêtises suffisante à elle toute seule
sans aide banque de marché que des
banques de marché pur on peut aller dans
le mur aussi donc ça ne servira pas à
tout régler ça peut ça peut donner une
certaine assurance quant aux opérations
hors marché qu'on appelle dans le
langage moderne le shadow banking
c'est vrai qu'il faut arriver à le à le
réguler d'une certaine façon moi je suis
sans être un grand spécialiste je pense
que fondamentalement sur tous ces sujets
de paradis fiscaux de hedge-fund
d'opérations hors marché
c'est un régal en régulant correctement
les banques qu'on les réguler
parce que quand vous avez un et funky
qui fonctionne ou des opérations de
shadow banking massif elles ont leurs
contreparties dans des prêts qui sont
faites par des banques new-yorkaises
londonienne où voir française donc il ya
une certaine hypocrisie dans ce domaine
là et donc si on veut vraiment si vous
voulez que les choses soient soient plus
transparentes
il faut arriver à discipliner un peu
plus ses banques et autant je trouve que
bâle iii si vous voulez et sans doute et
surtout sous la pression des marchés va
être une contrainte forte autant sur ce
point là je pense qu'il ya peut-être
encore des des trous dans la raquette
comme on dit familièrement voilà ce que
m'inspire votre question alors les
critiques sur la mf m'ont effectivement
il ya toujours eu des critiques 1 sur le
régulateur alors elles sont je les ai
intériorisé depuis longtemps elles sont
elles sont souvent difficiles à subir
lorsqu'on voit que si vous voulez ifs
elles sont parfois adressé par des gens
qui n'ont pas content
science de ce que peut faire le
régulateur et de ce qu'il ne peut pas
faire c'est à dire parfois il le
régulateur fait des erreurs et je
pourrais vous en citer énormément et
bien sûr il n'est pas infaillible mais
il ya des fois où si vous voulez il ne
peut rien moi j'ai par exemple des
souvenirs pendant la bulle
moi je voyais passer des dossiers à
l'introduction en bourse qui était
extraordinaire j'avais envie de les
bloquer je ne pouvais pas juridiquement
tout ce qu'on pouvait c'était m faire
une note d'avertissement
donc on avertit c'est en disant à
l'épargnant de faire attention en
investissant sur ce titre parce que
c'était une entreprise internet qui
avait encore pas de business models
comme on dit fiable est une valeur très
très grande proposé par rapport à la
réalité
les épargnants acheter quand même et
j'en ai qui nous ont écrit après
pourquoi parce que tout le monde leur
disais que ça allait augmenter de 15%
dans les dix jours dont qu'ils y
allaient et leurs régulateurs là ne
pouvait rien de la même façon si vous
voulez les décisions la crise financière
est pour partie liée à l'afflux de
liquidités qui vient de la politique que
k line dance panne a mené il ya une
dizaine d'années ça a eu des
répercussions sur les marchés mais la
capacité de la m f si vous voulez à
contrer une opération aussi vaste que
celle des subprimes étaient extrêmement
difficiles donc à la fois je partage
complètement votre sentiment
et c'est une des raisons pour moi de
revenir un peu parce que quand je suis
parti
je pensais qu'on avait fait des avancées
multiples sur beaucoup de terrain mais
que fondamentalement parce qu'on était
déjà en pleine crise on n'avait pas à
assumer complètement notre mission de
protection
alors je vous jure pas que je suis
beaucoup mieux armées contre tout
mouvement de marché 1
simplement je pense qu'on a progressé en
mon absence beaucoup sur la
commercialisation
j'ai parlé avec les équipes j'ai parlé
avec jean pierre jouyet il ya une
direction de la commercialisation des
produits financiers ont peu progressé
sur la manière dont les produits sont
présentés à l'épargnant mais quand il ya
des phases d'engouement ou des phases de
dépression les comportements collectifs
l'emportent souvent et il est difficile
pour le régulateur de faire face à la
marée
moi j'ai gardé une leçon ces deux parce
que nous avions un chez nous nous avions
une équipe très brillante qui avait
prévu un petit peu la crise des
subprimes et si vous si on a eu un
séminaire collège on a fait une
publication
malheureusement elle était un peu
technique et elle est restée dans notre
revue elle a été peu relayé par la
grande presse
mais on avait noté noir sur blanc que
les agences de notation avaient à une
évolution très importante dans la
répartition de leurs chiffres d'affaires
et qu'elle notait des produits
structurés que nous ne connaissions pas
bien aux états unis dans des proportions
très importantes et si on avait eu des
économistes ou des journalistes qui
s'étaient positionnés davantage là
dessus on aurait sans doute pu avoir des
gérants professionnels qui se
précipitent moins pour acheter du triple
a qui n'en étais pas donc il ya à la
fois vous avez raison je pense que je
suis pas trop mal je partage votre
sentiment
j'en ai gardé le sentiment qu'il fallait
quand on on notait quelque chose comme
ça parler haut et fort tout en sachant
quand même que l'on n'est pas toujours
entendus parce qu'il ya un court
termisme terrible dans le monde de la
finance
voilà sur la mmf sur sur la place
financière de paris
moi j'ai déjà parlé dont je veux pas
trop haut trop revenir là dessus je
pense que il faut avoir une discussion
entre bercy et les grandes banques les
grandes banques sont très puissante en
france elles sont en ce moment en train
de faire une mutation très grand
du fait de bâle iii le sujet place de
paris est pour elle un peu second et
c'est pas le cas à londres
donc je pense qu'on peut reprendre la
main sur certains points on a encore une
fois des points forts en matière de
gestion il faut les utiliser sur le rôle
le rôle de la mf en matière de taxe sur
les transactions financières sincèrement
je pense que c'est essentiellement un
sujet législatif
on peut répondre aux questions donner
des éclairages techniques au bout d'un
moment il ya une responsabilité
politique il ya une question de
négociations internationales
c'est pas la mf denis de faire le texte
ni de l'appliquer bien sûr si on voit
des fraudes on dénotera très bonnes
questions sur à laquelle je n'ai pas de
réponse véritablement de la part de
monsieur arthuis ce qui au fait orfèvres
en ce domaine
on va vers une neuro pénalisation du
contrôle bancaire
ça va prendre un certain temps parce que
c'est quand même difficile je pense
qu'on ira un jour vers une
européanisation du contrôle des marchés
mais ça mettra encore plus longtemps
d'abord parce que les anglais ils sont
farouchement opposés deuxièmement parce
que vous avez d adhérence avec le droit
des sociétés qui sont très très
importante et j'ai moi même enfin je
m'intéresse beaucoup au droit boursier
jeu les enseigner à dauphine et à
sciences po et on passe
insensiblement du droit boursier au
droit des sociétés et quand vous allez
en allemagne en hollande au luxembourg
en italie les traditions de droit des
sociétés sont pas les mêmes
donc quand on veut unifier le
la régulation on tombe assez facilement
dès qu'on parle de droits des opéras de
gouvernance d'entreprise on tombe sur
des sur des sujets qui sont pas très
facile mais globalement ça serait mieux
de s'organiser et une de mes priorités
sincèrement je les dis dans mon
introduction mais vous n'êtes peut-être
pas la cde d'être le plus actif possible
au sein de l'esma parce que la mf a été
la cob à l'origine de l'esma et pour des
raisons peut-être un peu de balancier
d'autres pays que nous ont repris ont
repris le rôle de fall le leadership et
je pense sans vouloir être leader que
l'on doit être important là dedans et
jouer un rôle sur ce terrain là sur le
contrôle des comptes de la mf la cour
des comptes contrôle la nfl a fait
plusieurs rapports je suis pas très
inquiet je pense que ça n'interdit pas
d'avoir un commissaire aux comptes
on pourrait la voir ce serait pas mal
honnêtement je pense pas qu'il ya
énormément de sujets comptable j'ai
rencontré dans le passé une grave
difficulté que j'avais expliqué au
collège pendant un moment on a été très
défaillant sur l'encaissement des
recettes au moment de la bulle
on était tellement pris par le par les
opérations elles-mêmes que l'assiette et
le paiement ne s'était pas bien fait on
a repris la main mais ça date déjà d'il
ya sept huit ans
si on avait un commissaire aux comptes
il nous aurait peut-être fait remarquer
que nos procédures d'assiette des
recettes n'étaient pas correctes là ça
c'est moi comme secrétaire général
d'abord qu'il avait laissé faire j'avais
eu tort et qui ensuite repris la main
mais ça c'est derrière nous et la cour
des comptes l'a vérifié pour le reste je
pense qu'on peut réfléchir à votre
suggestion
j'ai répondu si vous le permettez je
pense que la cour des comptes fait un
travail de commissaire aux comptes et
donc si elle voulait bien examiner
chaque année vous compte
rien ne s'empêche l'empêcherait de
exprimé une opinion qui seraient publiés
dans notre rapport
ceci pour éviter des frais
supplémentaires oui c'est vrai c'est
vrai que la cour a plus fait un rapport
sur la régulation financière elle a bien
entendu vérifier à les opérations
comptables mais à une optique plus large
et elle a pas à ma connaissance mais
j'étais déjà parti je pense pas qu'elle
ait réellement certifié je pourrais
peut-être voir ça avec eux vous
ça me paraît être une bonne idée
sincèrement et ce serait à faire dans
toutes les allées à ce moment là merci
beaucoup monsieur rameix vous avez
répondu je crois de manière très très
très intéressante et enfin dans un peu
la clairance à certains moments
notamment la question sur la mf les
responsabilités de la mmf et je crois
que vous nous apporter tous les éléments
nécessaires pour que nous réfléchissions
bien sur le chemin de la salle
habituelle de nos séances avant
d'émettre un vote
voilà merci infiniment de votre présence
de ce que vous nous avez dit vous venez
de suivre l'audition de gérard rameix
pour revoir les travaux du sénat notre
site internet publicsenat.fr
à très bientôt